what about uh marriage at a young age
like is that cutting your feet i think
it's the worst thing in the world but
some people could pull off he pulled it
off
um i mean i'm 35. so yeah he's still
young yeah okay still a youngster but
it's good for some people except cause
sometimes marrying somebody can motivate
you because right now you're not married
you're single you you've been married in
the past never been married never been
married yeah never never proposed or
nothing like that no no that's corny as
hell to me
how many children do you have i have
seven how many baby mamas seven oh so
you're okay
yeah three three three one nine stands
seven children and i've made love to
some of the most beautiful women in the
world but i nutted
in the most seven unsuccessful [ __ ]
the world has ever seen
hmm
yeah ain't nothing
ain't none of my baby mom is rich
so i wish one of them could have been
[ __ ] that's just a joke that's
gonna laugh that's some funny [ __ ] but
no shout out to my kids moms but you
know my um
that life is for me like my oldest son
he's like dad i don't want to be like
you you know i want to have a family and
i said okay son well
have your own family and have your own
[ __ ] kids and you could have
everybody under one roof
the reason why i say this on the air is
that i want people to understand
to avoid depression you have to play the
hand that you dealt
see if you play your hand and know who
you are you're going to be happy but
when you start looking at somebody
else's [ __ ]
or start thinking well what if exactly
then those were your the problems come
the issues if you accept the hand that's
given to you and you just deal with it
and look forward yes and
your happiness will be but like you said
when you start pocket watching other
people exactly people watching other
relationships people who you perceive to
be your peers maybe in the same field
yes or you start dwelling too much on
what could have happened yes what should
have happened yes then you're gonna
[ __ ] you're done right and it all
goes back to your nature like you said
earlier right we all get jealous we all
get angry right so i tell people control
your emotion it's one of the most if you
can train yourself over the years to
control your emotions
you won
that's real you won you have one i swear
to god because once you're in control
you still get the anger like
yeah but control your control that's why
i tell people to rest as much as you can
the night before because when you're not
well arrested you get angry easier
you'll snap at somebody you hurt
somebody because you didn't have proper
sleep the night before
so when people say hey
old people go to bed early you know i go
to bed early but i wake up i can go to
bed 10 o'clock still wake up before you
it's feel like i slept all day you know
that's because me i worked so hard and
my whole life and got successful that i
just enjoy
life
like i like getting up early
and start the whole my [ __ ] day
because this is i enjoy it well there's
a different energy i feel like when you
really finally grow up
you stop sleeping until like 11 a.m
right you start waking up before eight
you realize like
this like this like your your life your
day just becomes so much more productive
right because look at what you mean to
yourself right you look forward to doing
this yeah this makes you feel successful
your wife knows where you're going you
feel good about it
even when you talk to someone about what
you have
you may not realize but i'm telling you
what it sounds like accomplishment
you accomplish something that's
motivating you own something you're
doing something yeah and i always tell
guys as you get older you sit down with
a woman
when you start saying what you've done
and what you're about to do and not be
lying
it makes a woman [ __ ] where it makes
her interested in you because you have
accomplishments and that's what a man
should also look at the female okay babe
i see the fat ass
see the bad guys
where's your head at what have you
accomplished you're 30 something but
what have you account are you a real
estate agent did you graduate from
college do your own eyelash shop do you
do what do you own yeah what are your
aspirations what's your aspirations man
that's deep but that's what people
should look at it's a lot of
[ __ ] man right now i'm telling
you
is there a bare minimum because you said
uh a guy should be have 25k it's not
really 25 000. for a female no no it's
really not the idea that 25k is more
like just have something just have
something it's just a metaphor i just
threw that number out what i'm saying
for females now this should be the same
same but have something right you know
like
a woman should have money not to give to
a man
right a woman should have money too that
she's with a guy really the way i came
up with this if two people had money
when they meet and it didn't work out
guess what the transition has got she's
gonna give me a place you could get this
you play smooth if one person is broke
one's gonna try to hold on to the other
person don't want to really leave
or
you're so [ __ ] up you're gonna stay
you gotta stay in the house because you
guys are both on the lease right you're
gonna stay in a situation that's because
financially you don't have another
option
i don't want to go back to my mother's
right i don't wanna go to my brother's i
can't go with my sister i burnt that
bridge
so i know it's hard to understand what
i'm saying but before you even put
yourself in that situation try to get
the money but you know what most 90
people do
they [ __ ] get the girl pregnant
and then they behind the eight ball